bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fatti j
oggi siamo tornati su game perfetto
ragazza allora il primo episodio di
hunger games è stato stupendo cioè a mio
parere è stata una delle cose che mi
sono divertito di più a fare su youtube
oggi ragazzi ho voluto replicare
l'episodio di hunger games con nuovi
personaggi e quindi ragazzi vi presento
i tributi di oggi per il distretto 1 fa
vj con dei baffi molto anni 42 e corni
il che sarebbe chi non è lui è lui il
mio pupazzo quello il letto si chiama
cornhill lo zio dobbiamo fare i cui i
culi a strisce dobbiamo fare a strisce
per il distretto due skin è lartigue
array per il distretto 3 ariana grande
barba j
mia madre sempre gli stretto fatto da
gianni morandi e le mani di gianni
morandi perché ovviamente erano talmente
grosse che non stavano nella foto di
prima quindi ho dovuto creare un
personaggio a parte come per i capelli
gli sta stretto 5 john cena ed errico
pasquale pratico per il distretto 6 ed
iran è quello giapponese che fa il suo
ritorno in grande stile ristretto 7 mara
maionchi e olimpia ma donia che quella
di avanti un altro per il distretto 8
james e gesù distretto 9 justin bieber e
la pasta dal formaggio per il ristretto
10 pedro che è quello di per me la
cipolla e e la cipolla per il distretto
11 renzi e gli ottavi e infine ragazzi
per il distretto 12 ho voluto lasciare
katniss e peeta perché ci sta
voglio vedere se pita riuscirà ad aver
la meglio su un piatto di pasta al
formaggio che comincino e il 778 esimi
hunger games
siamo partiti ragazzi il bagno di sangue
e la partenza è sempre quella che miete
più vittime martin garics prende una
lancia dall'interno della cornucopia che
sarebbe il pezzo centrale di dove
partono gli hunger games vita colpisce
la testa di skin con una mazza si
attacca attaccati al cazzo game corre
via dalla casa non mi fa troppo ridere
vedere james enrico pasquale pratico e
fa vj combattono per 1 0
ma vj sede e batte in ritirata grazie al
ricco appassionato alla zappa dall'osso
culo gianni morandi riceve un esplosivo
da uno sponsor sconosciuto è stata anna
glielo dà gli ha dato anna mamma j stoxx
james mia madre store chiara james jones
in agli hobby fa vj e peeta cacciano gli
alla madonna che timbra di una grande e
batte justin bieber in una battaglia ma
lo lascia vivere alla grande che fa il
culo a justin bieber questa non l'avevo
ancora sentita fa vj corre via da bar
magenta cosa è sempre successa quando io
tornavo da scuola con un 4 e leggo la
ciabatta tentare aiutino non è una
novità sempre così vedono la cipolla e
del sheeran uccidono pasta al formaggio
mica che che siete proprio dei degli
animali cazzo ed sheeran intima james di
uccidere ariana grande o la maionchi
lui decide di uccidere la maionchi
ovviamente di cazzola lucida nella
grande famiglia in prenderlo zaino ma
non realizza che è vuoto
olimpia ma donia petrone del c ran
combattono mauri via madonna trionfa
uccidendoli entrambi morto sheeran molto
pedro bravo olimpia martin garics e fa
vj dormo cosa martin garics farisei
dormono a turno perché nel senso che ci
diamo i turni di notte per dormire
quando sto sveglio io faccio i video da
urlo quindi non sveglio quando sta
sveglio lui fa i pezzi che sparano i
bassi quindi sto sveglio anch'io alla
fine non ha dormito cazzo nessun tributi
morti sono pasta al formaggio e basta
fantastico ragazzi pasta formaggi e
morta io toby lascia entrare gesù nel
suo rifugio
bellissimo vorrei vederla st scena ha un
non so che di epico con il e fa vj si
raccontano storie l'una all'altro era
stato mica lo sanno come che si fanno
sapere una certa noi lo facciamo sempre
quello giapponese insegue gesù una
pioggia acida cade sulla rena oh mio dio
justin bieber colpisce mamma j
e la lascia morire nella affanculo
justin quello giapponese tira una
facciata in una pozza di dio in una
pozza di pioggia acida questa fa male
ariana grande rifiuta enrico pasquale
pratica non l'avrei mai detto per j
non ho ucciso io topi però poi c'è il c
degli ottavi e mi spiace de karim scusa
scusa micari non volevo è stata la
pioggia era incazzato per mia madre è
stata la pioggia giuro ciglio trovi
lasciando nella pioggia amori rive
gianni morandi sopravvive martin harris
verso di sopravvivono zein anche zen con
la faccia nell'acido cazzo
credo che gli one direction non avranno
più questo successo a me che non fa
parte dei one direction incasso dico
tutti con le facciate nelle porte
ovviamente piove acido e cosa facciamo
affittiamo la faccia nelle pozzanghere
ovvio 10 cala madonna quanti sono morti
pedro ed sheeran renzi maionchi mia
mamma quello giapponese eriko pasquale
pratico yotobi james e le mani di gianni
mica un genocidio notte due solo alla
notte due sono morti in 45 come cazzo è
possibile skin muore di vicente
dissenteria
martin garics strangolarli ad agra e
belli ha rubato le cose quindi sono gli
ha strangolato a era grande e fantastico
justin bieber implora cornhill di
ucciderlo ma lui rifiuta lasciando
justin bieber vivo no che cazzo fai ha
ucciso mia madre che cazzo fai gesù e fa
vj si stringono per scaldarsi
oddio mio tg correvi ad accordi e te
credo che ho infilato un cazzotto in
bocca sono morti skinner e la grande
rilievo che è rimasto distretto 1 il re
cornhill olimpia gesù justin bieber la
cipolla katniss e peeta perfetto katniss
ferisce a morte justin bieber e lo
lascia morire
mammamia katniss mamma mia che don
gianni morandi cade in un burrone muore
un vulcano erutta al centro dell'arena
con il e sepolto nella cenere o cazzo si
stava guardi sta pure bene
katniss soffoca martin garics sopravvive
pita colpisce john cena la sfinge john
cena nella nave ok no no no al
bellissimo fa vj manda cesure del cep
spinge gesù nella nava
ma gesù lo prende e lo tira con sé e
quindi siamo annegati nella lava
entrambe a car e la cipolla soffoca 9
madonna quanti sono morti justin bieber
gianni morandi cornet john cena fa dj
gesù la cipolla e olimpia è rimasto il
martin garics e peeta martin garics
fitta sono rimasti stilisti 2 scontro
decisivo martin garics uccide vita è il
vincitore dei 770 tesimi hunger games
martin garics blondes io sono fiero
harada chissà nono posto è chi sta a
destra lista stessa
la pasta formaggi arrivata ultima non
l'avrei mai detto quindi ragazzi miei
colloqui l'episodio spero che vi sia
piaciuto è stato e quanto strano rifare
questa cosa però ogni volta che faccio
mi piace sta cosa è bellissima anche
ragazzi crollo che l'episodio spero che
i video vi sia piaciuto e cosa sei così
vita è piaciuta lasciato momento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e con
noi vita trattamento iniziale se non
sapresti discrete ci vediamo al prossimo
video dove ragazzi ricordatevi che le
mani di gianni fanno più male di quanto
pensiate non vorreste mai scoprirlo
credetemi
beh ragazzi dove è finita la nostra
amicizia dove vent'anni passati a
dormire con te che cazzo sono serviti
[ __ ]